today on the matt walsh show a new york
times writer provoked outrage among
feminists when she published a piece
saying that she's happy about being a
mother
those kinds of shocking and outrageous
statements simply cannot be tolerated
apparently
we'll discuss also five headlines
including rand paul and dr fauci
clashing once again
the cdc director warns about the
unspecified dangers of summer camp for
children and another famous celebrity
comes out
against cancel culture and our daily
cancellation today we'll talk about the
media in hollywood's
brave stand against the racism of the
golden globes how are the golden globes
racist
we'll try to figure that out today and
much more on the matte wall show
[Music]
you are of course already on thin ice in
this culture if you make your own
decisions
and live your life according to values
that fall outside of the mainstream even
if you do this quietly in an unobtrusive
and unassuming way it'll still be
considered an affront to those who for
whatever reason
are personally offended by your personal
choices but if you god forbid openly
advocate for those values and express
satisfaction with the choices that
you've made
then you have really crossed the line
crossed the line at least in the minds
of our leftist
cultural overlords who have gone to
great lengths to tell us
what our values should be and what kind
of life we should lead and they do not
appreciate having their instructions so
blatantly ignored
new york times opinion writer elizabeth
brunig discovered this fact over the
weekend in the lead-up to mother's day
after writing a piece
on the subject of motherhood that
provoked great outrage on the left
especially among feminists
now we should note that brunig is no
right-wing radical she's certainly on
the left herself she's also
no fan of mine for the record she has a
long-standing and rather passionate
distaste for me in all of my opinions
this is kind of surprising as i'm
usually beloved by liberal women
in any case none of that saved brunig
from the blowback for the piece she
published with this
shocking title get ready for it the
title is
i became a mother at 25 and i'm not
sorry i didn't wait
provocative stuff at least provocative
for those who believe that women should
not say anything about motherhood
unless they're saying that they regret
being mothers or that they're happy they
never became mothers
like those are the two things that as a
woman you're allowed to say publicly
about motherhood
the piece as the title suggests is
simply all about brunic's decision to
become a mother at a comparatively young
age
and how and why she's happy that she did
it now of course 25
is not really a young age to have a
child back when your great-grandmother
was having babies
25 would have been considered downright
geriatric
um to start the process but even today
in some circles uh and even today in
some circles 25 is
is not really young my wife was around
that age when when we had our first
child or children twins
but broadly speaking the average age for
marriage and for having children has
been rising
dramatically in this country for years
now
so now on average women are waiting
until 28 to get married and men
until 30. of course not everyone
gets married before having kids
unfortunately but this this is generally
the way things are trending
in in the circles that a liberal
cosmopolitan woman like brunig runs in
the age for marriage and children is
going to be probably considerably higher
even than that
so again from a comparative standpoint
25 is young
as for the article i have to admit even
though she hates my guts she writes kind
of beautifully
here's here's one part she says quote
what i didn't understand
couldn't have at the time was that
deserting yourself for another person
really is a relief
my days began to unfold according to her
schedule
that weird rhythm of newborns and the
worries i entertained were better than
the ones that came before
more concrete more vital less tethered
to the claustrophobic confines of my own
skull
for this member of a generation famously
beset by anxiety it was a welcome
liberation
liberation she's talking about the
liberation of motherhood
which of course is the opposite of what
we so often hear that women are
liberated
by leaving the home leaving motherhood
by liberating even by killing their own
children
but she's taking the opposite
perspective and it's very well said and
what she says
is profoundly true but many on the left
didn't feel that way feminist writer and
miserable
cat lady amanda marcotte said that the
piece was quote
naked pandering to the fantasies of
pathetic men
and further offering her thoughts she
wrote quote i would like to thank this
headline
byline combo for helping me set a record
for the quickest
gross pass i've ever uttered in my life
feminist author jude ellison sadie doyle
who looks exactly as you'd expect a
feminist author with four names to look
tweeted this the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing this
woman it was a tremendous personal
achievement to be repeatedly knocked up
by an internet troll that she met in
high school
another imagine imagine saying that in
response to
a woman writing something on mother's
day about how she's happy to be a mother
what you think it's an achievement to be
knocked up
my god these people are miserable
another blue check on twitter um jackie
shine
accused brunig of claiming that her life
decisions are superior to other people's
and another
aura bugatto somehow found in the piece
evidence of quote white extinction
anxiety
and there was plenty more where all this
came from but you get the idea
brunig expressed a point of view that
you're not supposed to express and this
was the reaction
for example for an example of the point
of view that you are supposed to express
the point of view that you are supposed
to have as a mother or a parent
here's feminist writer jill filopovich
also last week around the same time as
the hullabaloo over the bruneg article
she tweeted this
i would really love to read more essays
and op-eds from women
and men too who regret having children
as early as they did regret having as
many as they did
or regret having children at all there's
not much about motherhood that remains
publicly unexplored
but that does
yes regret resentment
misery that's what jill flopovich would
like to hear from others
certainly that gratitude love happiness
or any other such
repulsive emotion and she wrote a longer
piece by the way
explaining why she tweeted that and and
and how this is a taboo
this is one of the last taboos in our
society for mothers to talk about their
regret
and uh and they we we should deconstruct
that taboo and
mother should be able to talk about this
of course it's actually not a taboo you
hear parents talk about their regrets
all the time
far too often but also by the way
one of the reasons
why you might not hear mothers saying
that aloud very often is first of all
most mothers don't regret having kids
and second if you do regret it like
that's probably the kind of thing you
shouldn't say publicly
because your kids are going to read that
one day and maybe you don't want to
announce to the whole world hey i regret
having this human right here
now i think there are two general points
uh to be made
about the the overall issue here first
of all it is indeed a good idea
to start a family while young that's a
good idea
uh i don't think that elizabeth brunig
was necessarily
pitching this as a as a strategy for
everyone but she was just talking about
her own choices
i will pitch it though i do think it's i
think it's a generally speaking a good
idea
again general statement it's not going
to be true in every single case
there are also many examples of people
both women and men who very much
wanted to have a family earlier in life
but were unable to for one reason or
another
nobody's suggesting that you're doomed
to a life of pointless misery if you
have kids at 34
or if you never have them at all we're
simply talking about or at least i'm
talking about
general principles and as a general
principle it is better
to have a society where young parenthood
is the norm rather than the exception
that is
better why well for one
biology i know we don't care much for
biology these days
but it does matter it's a reality the
prime child bearing years for women are
between
around the age of 20 and up to about 34
or 35 give or take a year to on either
end
once a woman is out of those prime years
the um the chance of miscarriage of
health complications with the mother or
child etc go way
up a woman's body a woman's body
seems to have an opinion about when
women should be having kids and that
opinion differs
from the career first priorities of
modern society
also it's good for marriage and family
to be the foundation
of adult life rather than the capstone
see these days we have this idea that we
ought to get married and have kids
once we have all of our other affairs in
order and all of our finances
straightened out and
we're out we've already bought the house
and we've done all that we've
established our adult existence
and then we fit a family into that
already pre-established
mold now this can it's it
sounds maybe intuitively like it makes
sense to do things this way
but it can cause major problems
especially in a marriage
because now there's a feeling that
you're bringing someone into this thing
that you have already built without them
you've been an adult for a long time
you've lived your whole life without
this person
you've done all of this that all of this
was was you didn't need their help for
it
and now you're bringing them into it
the children too you're bringing into
this thing that has been long since
established before they ever showed up
they become
or they can seem like intruders
more so than partners in a journey now
in my case getting married and starting
a family younger
all that we have now and we've built
we've done together
my wife and i we walk the journey of
young adulthood together as a team
moreover there's something to be said i
think for having kids
when you still have the physical energy
to keep up with them
boys especially need a dad who can run
around
wrestle pick them up toss them in the
air climb into trees to rescue them when
they've climbed too high and so on
the great thing is that when you have
children young you can do all that stuff
with them
and you may even be able to do some of
that some of it with your grandchildren
if my kids have kids when i did i'll be
in my mid-50s when grandchildren arrive
on the scene
if those kids have kids at the same age
then i'll be around to see my
great-grandchildren
though i'll probably be as mentally
present and cognizant as joe biden by
then but still i'll be there
the point is younger marriage and
parenthood means multi-generational
families it means
kids who get to grow up with parents
grandparents and great grandparents
so having kids young pays dividends in
the long run
but you have to care about the long run
you have to be able to look outside of
the immediate
you have to have priorities that go
beyond comfort and convenience in this
present fleeting moment because it is
certainly true
while there's a lot of joy to be found
in having a family
um it is oftentimes not very comfortable
and it's certainly not convenient
it is never the most convenient thing
your life will
will become no part of your life will
become more convenient once you have
kids
that's for sure in fact very many things
that you didn't even think about before
now become a thing they become an
issue um they become even a source
potentially of conflict
that's how it is to have kids
but underneath all of that is the joy
waiting to be
found and felt and explored and that
brings us to the second point
you know that's what makes left wingers
and feminists so upset i think
because their operating principle their
priority
is to maximize surface level pleasure
in each moment as each moment passes you
say to yourself
how can i feel the most comfortable
and feel the most immediate pleasure in
this moment
and then you do whatever you need to do
for that
the problem is that this strategy has
rapidly diminishing returns
whereas the deeper joy of family life
can increase with age
i mean just talk to uh someone who just
recently became a grandparent
and then the joy that they experienced
there
and they'll leave they'll tell you that
it's it's it's not that it's
better than being a parent but it's a
new kind of joy that they've never
experienced before
so the joys can increase with age and
also
that decision to have a family while
young reaps new rewards at each stage of
life
the pleasure of living a life consumed
only by your own personal immediate
satisfaction
uh and material gain tends on the other
hand to fade over time and i think
this is why feminists only get more and
more bitter as they age you look at
someone like amanda marcotte or
jill filopovich or any of these
feminists have been on the scene for a
long time
and you look at their writing they've
just gotten angrier and angrier as they
get older
because they're lonely and miserable and
they realize
that their approach to life has failed
them
and they and it is envy they look at
like someone like elizabeth
brunic made a different decision is
experiencing the joy of that
and it makes them envious and hateful
if they can't have joy then they don't
want you to have it either
it really is as simple as that for them
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right so rand paul
versus dr fauci
once again um another another hearing
dr fauci was there and we we always get
you know rand paul throughout this
entire
without the last year you know he's been
one of the
few people in congress republicans even
um who've consistently taken the right
taken the right approach here
and have held dr fauci's feet to the
fire
and here he is again over the issue of
um
the national institute of health's
funding of the lab in wuhan where kovit
may have originated
uh fauci says that doesn't didn't happen
well originally he says it didn't have
any kind of back pedals but here's how
that exchange went
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect that the nih
has not ever and does not now fund
gain of function research dr barrett
does not doing gain or function research
and if it
is it's according to the guidelines and
it is being conducted in north
carolina i don't think it's concerning a
bat virus spike protein that he got from
the wuhan institute into the sars virus
his gain of function
that is not a minority because at least
200 scientists have signed a statement
from the cambridge working group
saying that it is gain of function well
it is not
and if you look at the grant and you
look at the progress reports
it is not gained a function despite the
fact
that people tweet that so you're trying
to report sending money to the wuhan
virology institute
we do not send money now to do one hun
sending money we did under your tutelage
we were sending it through eco health it
was a sub agency
and a sub grant do you support the money
from nih that was going to the wuhan
institute
let me explain to you why that was done
the saws cov1 originated
in bats in china it would have been
irresponsible
of us if we did not investigate
the bat viruses such a
dr fauci such an incompetent
dishonest little weasel i i'm i'm at the
point now
been there for a while actually of of
feeling
physical repulsion and even
like nausea when i look at him and i
hear him
can you think of a single bureaucrat in
the history of
the american republic that has done more
damage
to the country single-handedly
this has been one of the most
catastrophically damaging
bureaucrats i think government officials
that we've ever had in government
in this country and yet people still
there's still a lot of people
mostly on the left who looked at dr
fauci as this
as this father figure he's their cult
leader
beyond a father because he's a savior
figure to them
they love him and trust him implicitly
they literally sing songs of praise and
worship to him we've played some of them
here
you know what it is it's stockholm
syndrome i think that's what it is
like someone who's been we were he he
was responsible
largely responsible for pushing the
lockdowns across the country
destroying so many lives
and but at the same time he is is
trying to play the role of this kind old
man on on tv
saying reassuring words sort of
reassuring
reassuring but at the same time
spreading panic he's playing both ends
of the spectrum and
it's generated this kind of stockholm
syndrome
thing from a lot of people on the left
who now love their their captor
in a way but there he says uh well we
didn't fund the gain of function
research
uh that's interesting because here's a
here's a medium post from science writer
nicholas wade here's what he says
from june 2014 to may 2019
dr daz dassag's uh eco health alliance
had a grant
from the national institute of allergy
and infectious disease part of the
national institutes of health to do gain
of function research with coronaviruses
at the wuhan institute of virology
virology um whether or not
this is this again is nicholas wade
science writer in medium
whether or not sars 2 is the product of
that research it seems
questionable policy to farm out high
risk research to unsafe foreign labs
using minimal safety precautions
and if the sars2 virus did indeed escape
from the wuhan institute then and
then the nih will find itself in
terrible position of having funded a
disastrous experiment that led to death
of more than three million people
worldwide
including more than half a million of
its own citizens um
so that's what we get doc
ray and paul also dr paul says that
there was funding
here there's funding but dr francis
doesn't know no this
that's you're you're completely and
totally wrong
don't don't trust the facts that are
right in front of your face trust me
i'm dr fauci you can trust me
meanwhile the head of the cdc was also
um
questioned in this case questioned about
the ever-changing cdc guidelines
uh by miss questions back and forth with
susan collins and here's how that went
i used to have the utmost respect for
the guidance from the cdc
i always considered the cdc to be the
gold
standard i don't anymore
it matters because it undermines
public confidence in your
recommendations
in the recommendations that do make
sense
in the recommendations that americans
should be following
with regard to the new york times piece
this morning there's a
meta-analysis from journal of infectious
diseases that was published in november
i believe where the top-line result
of all collaborat all studies that were
included in the systematic review
said less than 10 percent of cases were
transmitted outdoors with regard to camp
i have a 16 year old
every day every year he comes home from
camp and he writes the number of days
until he returns to camp the next
year this year it got to zero and i told
him he wasn't going
i want our kids back in camp
we now have 38 000 new infections on
average
per day last may 11th it was 24
000 and we sent a lot of kids home and
camps were closed
the camp guidance is intended to get our
kids to camp
and allow them to stay there yeah we did
it last
may there's no reason to do it then well
we had this stupid
pointless policy last may so
it apparently didn't do anything it
didn't achieve anything
the fact that these people are still
using
are justifying the continuance of these
policies by saying well it's what we
were doing early on
apparently that didn't work did it
summer camp was never a problem was
never an issue it was never going to be
a vector for transmission
neither were schools we shut schools
down in may why should we open them now
i don't know if you give a damn at all
about the kids if you can if you care
about facts if you care about the signs
maybe that's why
maybe that's why you let them go to
summer camp
and i i just love it when these people
use their own kids
and their own experience as parents
you know in a way to give them sort of
emotional credibility
and she says well i've got a kid my own
son wants to go to camp and i can't let
him go
all you're proving is that you don't
give a damn about your own child
that's all that doesn't that doesn't
help your case at all
because as a cdc director if you've
looked at the data
which i'm going to assume you have
then you know that there is no reason
zero reason to keep kids out of summer
camp or to have them
wear masks when they're at summer camp
no reason to do it
there's never been a reason you have no
data they never presented
they never bother show us the data show
us the
show us the statistics show us the facts
give us the numbers
that actually prove why kids can't go to
summer camp
kids need to wear masks
vaccinated people have to wear masks you
know
anywhere like show us give us
information
show us a bar graph or something
they never ever do because they have
none of the facts on their side and they
know it
but the cdc director who is that dr
rochelle walensky
she has a lot of power now just like
fouchy
getting a lot of air time on camera
on the news i mean you have to
understand it probably wouldn't come as
any
surprise to you but to be in front of
cameras
all the time uh to have people talking
about you in the news
to have people hanging on your every
word
asking for permission to you know send
their kid to summer camp or something
like that
um that is the
the power is immense
and it can become addicting for people
it's kind of hard to let that go that's
what i've been saying all along
even if you're someone of great
personal integrity and self-control
it could still be very very difficult
when you're given that kind of attention
that kind of power that kind of prestige
all all of a sudden
now yeah these leeches and parasites
have been in government forever
wasting taxpayer dollars uh but nobody
cared dr fauci's
household name now across the country
how many people knew the guy's name
last january i mean nobody did nobody
cared
so they've been kind of yeah making a
lot of money
as parasites um on the system
but doing it in relative obscurity and
dr
fauci is whatever 70 plus years old and
that's how he's lived most of his life
and now all of a sudden over the last
year rock star status
getting the inten the attention and the
power that they believe they've always
been entitled to that's why they're in
these positions in the first place
and now they're saying after all these
years finally
dr rochelle wolensky is saying you know
what finally
you people you should be asking me
permission before you do anything with
your kids
i know better than you i've always known
now you're finally recognizing it
so to have that happen to suddenly be
elevated
in that way as we have taken all of
these all of these
useless bureaucrats and put them in
these positions uh that that
that's that's intoxicating again even
for
an honest virtuous person they could be
corrupted
but then what what do you do when the
people to begin with are not honest and
virtuous at all
what do you do when they're already
scumbags and then you give them that
kind of power
they're just they're not gonna let it go
they will never ever let it go
there will never be a time when rochelle
walensky gets in front of cameras and
said
everything's fine go live your lives she
will never ever say that mark my word
she will never say it
five years from now she won't be saying
it
all right moving on stacey abrams for
some reason was
um interviewed about the economic
recovery
i i really have no idea i've never been
able to figure out speaking of useless
people
uh stacey abrams what does she do why
does anyone care
about her at all um it's i mean it's one
thing if she's
a failed candidate and she's useless and
doesn't do anything
but she's got charisma and so people
like her for that reason but she doesn't
have any charisma
she's just this kind of blah lump on a
log figure
does nothing has achieved nothing but um
the media they love her anyway and they
always want to get her opinion so
she was being interviewed about the
economic recovery the alleged economic
recovery and she of course
of course approached it the only way
that she can approach the issue which is
by
making herself into a victim let's
listen
the u.s economy only added 266 000
jobs last month which was far less than
the more than 1 million that was
expected
it was so bad that there were reporters
on air that had to double check the
number
to make sure they had actually read it
correctly not to mention that the fact
that all the jobs
went to men is this a clear indication
that throwing money at this problem
isn't working
actually i would see a different way we
know this is a complicated challenge
a pandemic that's affected the economy
for women in
devastating ways and the notion that
recovery would happen
overnight is just it's unfounded
instead what we're seeing are the
combination of being able to survive the
pandemic
and start to build towards recovery and
i think that's why the american jobs
plan and the american families plan are
both so incredibly important
because it recognizes that the economy
of care which employs so many women
has got to be seen as an essential part
of how we rebuild our economy
and that it is insufficient for us to
simply focus on the more traditional
masculine areas of
the economy recognizing that we have to
have women in every area but that in
particular women have been hardest hit
and therefore we need intentional
engagement and intervention to rebuild
it back
more solidly traditional masculine areas
of the economy what even
are you babbling about what are you
talking about
why are you talking who are you these
are all questions that i have
by the way megan mccain says that we was
we added 266 thousand jobs she says
all of them went to men really
100 266 266 000
jobs out of 266 000 all of that not one
woman
earned a job in that in that time frame
is that i mean i don't have the
information right in front of me i kind
of doubt that
um but yes the the problem this is
really about
uh women we got to make this a problem
of women and
somehow we we throw sexism into it and
all of that and playing the same victim
card
as always this is this is actually
similar to what
the gop tweeted yesterday we talked
about the gop they were um
they were they were they were hitting
joe biden for not doing enough to get
mothers back to work
got a lot of these women that came out
of the workforce we got to get them back
in there
get that name tag back on them have them
a punch in a clock because that's what
we need women doing
what i would say to stacey abrams megan
mccain and the gop everybody
is uh yes
a lot of people lost jobs that's a bad
thing a lot of women lost jobs bad
people lose jobs
bad things especially when the gov job
is taken away from you by tyrants and
government makes it even worse
and um but
can we also consider the possibility
that
some of the women who left the workforce
and are and you know decided to stay
home with their kids over the last year
um if if we're not regaining those
those female jobs could could it be if
we're not we're getting them as quickly
as you thought we would or would like
for that to happen
could it be that there are some women
who have reassessed their priorities
and now they want to stay home with
their kids
can we leave open a possibility of
personal choice here
in fact i know that that is happening
of all the women who lost jobs and then
the number that haven't
that that have not uh regained a job i
don't know how many of them
have decided have reassessed their
priorities and decided that they want to
embrace this new lifestyle of staying
home with their kids and so on
being a homemaker and a stay-at-home
wife uh stay-at-home mom
i'm not sure how many of them but i do
know that that exists i've talked to
women i've gotten emails plenty of
women not people who
decided many times during the the
lockdown
for the first time that they're going to
become homeschool parents because they
had to
they didn't have a choice because all
the schools shut down because the
teachers
uh of course decided to prioritize their
own safety over over
the children and their education but
even though their safety was really
never at risk in any significant way
and there are a lot of people who
started homeschooling because they had
to and i'm sure many of them will as
soon as they can send those kids back
into school buildings
but a certain portion i think a not
small portion
are now saying you know what this is
good i i
it's tough to be a homeschool parent but
it's worth it
my kids are thriving i want to continue
this think that explains
a certain not small portion of the women
who remain
quote unquote unemployed
and i would consider that a positive
development actually
if now there are more families
homeschooling by choice
more mothers that want to stay home and
and take care of their kids education
and their children
rather than farming that out to the
school system or daycare center
by choice i'd consider both those to be
positive developments we should
celebrate that
all right from the new york post it says
donald glover
he's a well-known of course actor
rapper uh he tweeted over the weekend
and this has gotten a lot of reaction
and a lot of people are upset about it
for whatever reason he tweeted quote um
saw people on here having a discussion
about how tired they were of reviewing
boring stuff tv and film
we're getting boring stuff and not even
experimental mistakes because people are
afraid of getting canceled
so they feel like they can only
experiment with aesthetic
also because some of them know they're
not that good
and then it goes on with the reaction to
that and of course people on the left
they don't like it when
they don't like it when you acknowledge
cancel culture and when someone that
they thought is on their side and really
any famous celebrity
they assume is on their side and most of
them are when they come out and start
talking about cancer culture it feels
like a betrayal
and so that's the reaction that donald
glover has gotten
but but he's he's exactly right people
are
you know artists are afraid to
experiment afraid to try new things
and that's that's true that goes beyond
art though i think
one consequence of cancel culture
is that everything is boring uh our
discussion
about issues the debate on twitter and
on social media
it's it's getting more and more boring
it's not as fun as it used to be
and a big reason for that is that people
are yeah they're afraid
of saying something that they know is
going to upset people
obviously because of cancer culture but
people are also afraid of experimenting
yeah artists are afraid to experiment
artistically but i think people are
people are afraid to experiment with
ideas
which is something that we should
encourage
we should encourage it especially in an
educational environment
in particular in uh in in the you know
so-called higher education
in academia we should encourage people
to kind of
you you have an idea you're thinking
through something
you haven't thought it all the way
through you're not exactly sure
you know if you believe this or not but
it seems like an interesting thought on
this or that subject
and so you say it out loud and you kind
of start a conversation
and and ideally through that
conversation maybe you'll
you know your ideas start to firm up a
little bit more
and maybe ultimately you decide oh you
know what actually i'm not sure i really
believe that or maybe i'm wrong about
that
or you'll say yeah you know and the more
i talk about this the more we talk about
it the more i realize i'm right about
what i said
the kind of thing that should be
encouraged it also makes conversation a
lot more interesting
but you certainly get almost none of
that in the school system and in
academia that is
very much frowned on frowned upon and
you don't get it out in society either
you don't get
much of much of it on social media
you don't get much of people just saying
hey i'm throwing this idea out there i'm
not even sure how much i feel about it
but it's an interesting thought that i
had
because isn't that a normal thing then
we all have you know sometimes you're
thinking about something
an interesting thought pops into your
head and you think to yourself
hmm i'm not actually sure is it uh you
know i don't know if that's right
exactly but it seems
it seems like an interesting perspective
on this issue
and i assume i have those thoughts all
the time i assume most people do
but then you're afraid to say most
people are afraid to say it because they
know
um if they don't have it exactly figured
out and fully formed and they're ready
to launch
an aggressive defense they're going to
get eaten alive
and the consequence is one of the
consequences is that everything is just
kind of boring
people stick to you know
on every issue there are sort of
assigned opinions that you're supposed
to have whether you're on the right or
the left
and you know that if you're on the right
even if you even if you articulate one
of your assigned opinions
there's still going to be a blowback in
many cases
but still you want to most people they
stick within that kind of
pre-approved framework and i think even
conservatives will say
okay well here's the issue gun rights
gender whatever it is
um these are kind of the opinions that
that most people on this side seem to be
expressing
and so if i express that that point of
view i know what kind of blowback i'll
get it's already calculated it's already
it's already baked into the cake
but you're afraid to go beyond that and
to say oh you know what add another
thing here's another thought that i had
really is a tread it's it's it's a
tragedy um
because it makes not only everything
dull but it makes people into dull
thinkers all right
what else do we have here um okay one
other thing i wanted to show you this is
very important
this is from the account breaking911
on twitter they have this it's a it's a
they say it's a new 25 foot tall statue
unveiled in new york city rockefeller
center
and you can see it here we have it up on
the screen this is a statue to honor
african culture and here here it is
here's the statue
it's this giant large-headed
monstrosity in rockefeller center
the the ugliest statue i've ever seen in
my life
i think we have other angles some of the
other angles on this statue are you okay
there's another angle look at that thing
it's absurd it's like a cartoon
and it's to honor african culture
i don't even know what african culture
is exactly africa is a continent
there are many many different cultures
it's kind of like talking about asian
culture which people do talk about asian
culture but
there's a big difference between you
know india and china
so even that doesn't make a lot of sense
someone said that that
the statue it looks like the face you
make when your alarm goes
off at 5am which which i can kind of see
i kind of think it looks like a
self-portrait that a three-year-old
might draw
a three-year-old with gigantism anyway
but mostly it looks like you know what
it looks like it looks like crap
it looks like crap that's just that's a
terrible sculpture
well done to uh all involved all right
let's move on to reading the youtube
comments
evan says setting aside the fact that
gratitude is a virtue it's just a lot
easier to be happy in life
when you're grateful that's absolutely
true and yesterday we draw
the contrast between tim tebow and colin
kaepernick
as tebow is maybe getting back into the
league at a different position colin
kaepernick is still out of the league a
lot of reasons for that i went through
it yesterday but
uh but people also like tim tebow a lot
more he's easy to root for
and uh and because he's got gratitude
he's got humility and he seems like a
happy person
whereas colin kaepernick is just
miserable and spoiled
and complaining all the time and very
very
ungrateful for the many blessings in his
life
um alexis says does anyone click the
thumbs up button before watching the
video because you know you'll agree with
it and like it based on our love for
walsh
well i would certainly hope that
everyone does that
and those who don't obviously are banned
from the show if you're waiting to hear
what i have to say and to see how good
the show is before you hit the like
button
you know i'm not i'm not a a monkey
dancing for me for your amusement okay
i don't have to prove anything to you
hit the damn like button
right now and thanks for watching
um tim says i've always been amused by
the phrase sleep like a baby
what i remember and all i ever hear
about caring for infants is that you
don't get much sleep if sleeping like a
baby is such a desirable thing why are
the parents complaining so much yeah
i've never understood that phrase either
that's the
babies do sleep a lot they they sleep
like 20 hours a day
but uh almost none of that is at night
unfortunately and it comes in fits
they'll sleep for 30 minutes they're up
screaming and then they go down for two
hours and they're up some more
yeah so i guess when someone sleeps
sleep like a baby they mean the quant
they mean the quantity the amount of
sleeping but
in terms of the the way that you get
that sleep but no i wouldn't
i wouldn't recommend it um
scott says day 66 of begging matt to
play the banjo for us
we'll get to day 100 and then we'll talk
all right
um
and uh finally okay i wanted to get this
jade says hey matt what's your take on
stay-at-home dads
my soon-to-be wife will be making a lot
more money than me and i would like one
of us
at home when it comes time to have
children i'm okay with being a
stay-at-home dad
someday and she says she'd be okay
working full-time just want your
thoughts
um and as i
read that comment and now i'm actually
thinking maybe i shouldn't have read it
because there's not a lot i could say
here that won't get me in trouble
all i will say is that first of all well
first of all every family has its own
system that works for them so you have
to figure out a system that works for
you i'm a big believer in that
it's not a cookie cutter thing um but at
the same time
just two notes okay on the stay-at-home
dad thing
number one it's especially at the
youngest ages like newborn phase
the child really needs that maternal
presence
and needs it in fact a lot more than the
child needs the dad there that isn't to
say that a newborn doesn't need a dead
or that children don't obviously they do
and i'm always preaching that but
young babies really really need a mom
and mom can provide things not just
breast milk but that too
but other things maternal love and
soothing and comfort in
in a way that a man can't
a man can but it's not gonna be quite
the same so the idea of having the man
home rather than the woman
uh seems like it could be kind of
what's the word backwards that's
probably the wrong word i should have
chosen
but media matters will have fun with
that one um but no that is what i mean
actually i think if you have to choose
between
one or the other it makes sense for that
reason to have the woman
especially home with the baby at the
very young ages and also number two
what you could run into is your wife
says sure stay home that's great
but then finds that i've heard of many
cases like this
but then she finds over time that
she has she struggles to have respect
for a man who isn't bringing home the
bacon
i'm not saying that's right or that she
should feel that way but i am saying
that many women
you know they want their man to be out
there earning a living and so on
contributing to the family
in that way even if they initially say
otherwise
um and so there could be conflict that
can arise from that so those are my two
those are my two warnings that's all but
at the end of the day
make your own choice for your family now
a word from
all form you know the star of any living
room as we all know
is the the couch the sofa and uh
and you you want the sofa to be a lot of
times i know
in my family we've had a debate my wife
and i uh
is is when we're getting furniture
what's more important does it look nice
or is it the comfort that matters most
i'm firmly in the car i don't care what
it looks like i just wanted to be
comfortable
my wife is on the other side of it um
but with all form
sofas we kind of get both it threads
that needle if you've been listening to
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix mattress
well helix has gone beyond the bedroom
and they've started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form and they're already making the best
sofas
we've ever seen or sat in so what makes
it all for himself are really cool for
starters it's the easiest way
you can customize a sofa using premium
materials and at a fraction of the cost
of traditional stores
you can pick your fabric the sofa color
the color of the legs
sofa size and shape to make sure it's
perfect for you and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping
and if getting yourself without trying
it in stores sounds a little risky you
don't need to worry
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and what i love about it
again
that we with our sofa looks great and
it's extremely comfortable
and all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners
at allforum.comwalsh again all form
dot com slash walsh well if you've
noticed the country feeling
extra authoritarian lately you're not
alone and no it's not because i finally
come to power myself as the theocratic
dictator that's the good kind of
authoritarianism
right now we've got the the bad kind
we're experiencing um the country
certainly is feeling less and less free
in fact ben shapiro wrote an entire book
about that very subject the book is
called the authoritarian moment and in
it you'll find some solid tips for
fighting back against the left's
weaponization of everything we do
and consume from the colleges we attend
to the shoes we wear on our feet and
everything in between so
if you want to preserve your individual
rights and protect the ones you love
from mob rule the authoritarian moment
is now available for pre-order
at amazon barnes noble or any other
major bookseller
again the authoritarian moment go to
amazon get that book pre-ordered now
now let's get to our daily cancellation
i hope you're sitting down for this news
it's not it is now appearing
increasingly likely that we will be
deprived
of the golden globe awards next year it
may not air at all
now this needless to say is shocking i
for one cannot imagine what life will be
like without an award ceremony that i've
never watched
well come to think of it life will
probably be exactly as it was before
with no change at all but even so this
is startling stuff
the reason the golden globes has fallen
into such jeopardy is not that it's an
utterly pointless excruciating dull and
indulgent display of self-congratulation
by a drunken gaggle
of narcissists and drug addicts um it's
not as though all those involved in this
display finally said to themselves
you know what this is dumb and decided
to go shut it down no rather what
threatens the golden globes is a lack of
diversity
the new york post explains quote the
golden globes was on the verge of
collapse monday after stars
turned on the event and nbc dropped the
telecast for 2022 nbc abruptly pulled
the plug on airing the awards next year
citing the need for
meaningful reform by the embattled
hollywood foreign press association
um we quote we continue to believe that
hfpa is committed to meaningful reform
however change of this magnitude takes
time and work and we feel strongly that
hfpa
needs time to do it right the network
said in a statement monday according to
the hollywood reporter
reporter as such nbc will not air the
2022
golden globes assuming the organization
executes on its plan we are hopeful we
will be in a position to air the show in
january 2023
meanwhile the organization responded to
the cancellation with a statement
pledging to implement changes quickly
even with a
broadcast platform up in the air quote
regardless of the next air date of the
golden globes implementing
transformational changes as quickly and
as thoughtfully as possible
remains the top priority we invite our
partners in the industry to the table to
work with us on these
systemic reform that is long overdue
both in our organization as well as
within the industry at large
okay so the hollywood forum press
association needs reform
but what kind of reform do they need
after all their only job is to get
together
and just decide what movies they
personally liked
how do you reform an organization with
that kind of meaningless and subjective
purpose and why
bother reforming it well here are the
details
on the how and the why back to the
article says the hfpa has faced heavy
scrutiny for months
over alleged diversity and ethical
failings within its membership most
notably a lack of black members within
the 37 or rather the 87 member
organization
made up of international journalists
based in los angeles after a bombshell
l.a times report in february detailed
the group's lack of inclusion
bombshell it has a lack of inclusion
if you tell me bombshell and then you
tell me that the revelation is that
there's a lack of inclusion
i'm going to be disappointed um anyway
it says the time's up organization was
joined by hollywood notables including
shonda rhimes kerry washington judd
apatow melissa milano amy schumer
i think like none of them are actually
notable in my mind are more
are and more came in slamming the group
for its shortfalls
reiterating that a cosmetic fix isn't
enough
last week when hfpa revealed a draft
plan for reform which included a focus
a specific focus on recruiting black
members
time's up dismissed its contents as
window dressing platitudes
yes this is important the group of
random whoevers deciding which crappy
movies were the best in the past
calendar year
needs to include some black people
diversity and inclusion and
representation is the name of the game
of course
the people who advocate representation
never seem to consider what
representation actually means or looks
like
from a statistical perspective the fact
is that only 13 of the population is
black
that's a very small number which means
you're going to find a very small number
of black people in
many fields and areas of life it's not
racism it's just a numbers game
even if there are zero black people in a
given area
that's still pretty statistically
consistent as 13
of the population obviously isn't going
to translate into exactly 13
in every area and field you have to
allow for things like personal choice
the point is that when you hear that
there are no black members of hfpa
that isn't surprising it's a small
population pool
it also again doesn't matter because the
hfpa doesn't matter
a lot of people listening to this right
now probably didn't know the hfpa even
existed until they heard me
say it in this segment but the real
target of my cancellation today isn't
the golden globes which is already on
the cancellation chopping block without
my help
it's all of the shameless opportunistic
frauds in media and hollywood
just now pretending to care about this
issue
it cannot be a coincidence that nbc is
boycotting the golden globes over
diversity concerns
immediately after the golden globes
pulled the worst ratings in history
i mean this is much like colin
kaepernick deciding that he cares about
social justice
directly after he got benched in a
losing season for the 49ers
it's always amazing how people are
willing to sacrifice things
once those things that they're
sacrificing have proven less profitable
or desirable
so it's the old you know giving up
broccoli for lent tactic
a strategy as old as time various
celebrities have gotten the memo tom
cruise is returning his golden globes he
was
courageously inspired to take this stand
precisely when taking this stand would
cost him nothing
and earn only applause also returning
the actual physical trophies doesn't
achieve much i mean he still won the
award
so what is that i guess he won't be able
to sell the trophies at a pawn shop now
but something tells me that he's not
that hard up for cash i don't know
meanwhile scarlett johansson and mark
ruffalo have come out swinging against
hfpa
johansen condemned them for many things
including their association with harvey
weinstein
very brave and bold stuff for scarlett
johansson here i mean weinstein was
known to be an abuser in hollywood for
decades
and johansen waited until he was safely
behind bars
half dead and a national pariah before
she spoke out against
him this is what heroes are made of
folks
speaking of heroes mark ruffalo says
that he's ashamed
of the golden globes that he has won
quote now is the time to step
up and right the wrongs of the past
honestly as a recent winner of the
golden globe
uh goal of a golden globe i cannot feel
proud or happy about being a recipient
of this award
really he can't feel happy or proud well
that's definitely not how it seemed
three months ago when he won his latest
award
let's go back and watch that moment
again
[Applause]
i love you guys
oh gosh okay first of all this group of
actors these are these are my peers
these are the people i i
admire and love and and look up to so
i'm so honored
to be here with you guys um thank you
hollywood foreign press
thank you hbo thank you our production
team
thank my family who lets me go off and
bring these crazy people home and and uh
they have to live with uh all these
years thank you guys
um i don't know he certainly seems both
happy and proud there he could barely
contain himself
he's almost speechless he even
specifically thanks the racist
hollywood foreign press association this
was just past february just three months
ago
did he not care about diversity and
inclusion in february what changed
well i know it changed the tide changed
that's why netflix and amazon also both
denounced the hfpa
i'm sure that has nothing to do with
these actors taking this line by the way
they've all they have they've all
happened to denounce the hfpa at exactly
the time
when two of the most powerful
corporations in the movie boom movie
business did the same
you know crazy when these coincidences
line up this way this is what makes it
especially frustrating
to argue over these kinds of issues
because i can sit here all day and
explain
why diversity is not a virtue why it
doesn't make logical or moral sense to
make
racial inclusion your primary operating
principle
why the whole notion of representation
being advanced right now is off-base and
nonsensical etc
i can explain all of that and i can
argue my case and i can make my points
but i'll be talking to a brick wall
because the people i'm arguing against
don't really believe what they're saying
or care about the issue at all
it's a game it's a show it's a charade
it's all hollow it's all virtue
signaling
only what they're signaling is not a
virtue at all they're signaling at the
end of the day
their own emptiness and cowardice and
that is why the hollywood foreign press
association
is canceled but so is nbc so is mark
ruffalo so is scarlett johansson so is
netflix so is amazon
did i miss anyone i probably did all
canceled
uh for now and forever and we'll leave
it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show hamas
continues to fire hundreds of rockets
into civilian centers in israel
inflation numbers come out and they are
frightening and the biden administration
continues to lie about coveted
statistics that's on the bench shapiro
show today give it a listen